[Music]
i've seen scenes from the 4k version
and it's like i never saw the movie that
this 4k
remastering of the film so what leon
vitale
has been able to do by going in frame by
frame by frame from the
from the film negative of full metal
jacket is to pull out
information that when you're making a 35
millimeter print and it's going through
the machine
the machine's not able to to capture
the resolution you know whenever we did
a
a video release every single territory
you know they'd never it never happened
to them before
where we rejected their vhs's you know
as to
what they were going to release and then
of course the quality was so bad you
know
you know if you had to subtitle them
then you'd have to go through and
subtitle and check the subtitles check
them against the subtitles it went on
and on and on
doing a 4k remastering digital transfer
of the films
is what leon's able to do and because he
worked with stanley kubrick for
40 years leon was the only person
who stan lee's library
who understands the uh passion of
stanley kubrick
which one which one of the of all the
films is the most for you
re-watchable if you had the big one well
i can't say it because every time i do a
you know a transfer i mean i'm into it
as it is it's like yeah it's like asking
me what's my
favorite beatles album i couldn't tell
you
he's always asking himself what would
stanley do and
what would stanley accept you know and
he won't
allow something to be done that doesn't
reach those standards
i think it's unfortunate that that had
stanley still been alive
now and with netflix i think that he
could have realized the dream of
of telling a 15-hour story or
a 100-hour story a game of thrones
length story about napoleon's
uh life i mean people kind of peg him
into this you know he would have been
he would have astute working in digital
and
in film you know and shooting digital
film it's it's not
it's not true i mean what he would have
done is worked in the medium
and sort of got people to do it
or do it so that he could manipulate it
the way he wanted and then you know he
would have
he would have done it he would have done
it it was the same
it would have been same with drones it
would have been same with anything
you know every time we got a new color
stock we were
having to change ways of thinking about
lighting and
and you know if it was good he loved it
you